Welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today, Dr
Marty Macquarrie, who's a Johns Hopkins surgeon
and a New York Times bestselling author. His
book, the price we pay, what broke American
healthcare and how to fix it is available
now on Amazon. Um, I think a good place to
start is what did break American healthcare.
I mean, I'm former Cigna executive. Wendell
Potter writes in his very good book, deadly
spin about how in the period between World
War One and World War II, the u s was sort
of headed in the direction of a system, more
like many of the European systems. But at
the time it seemed to German when we were
not getting along with Germany, that plan
was abandoned and that was sort of the beginning
of the plan and the system that we have now.
How do you see the crux of how we got to where
we are now?
Well, people have a lot of opinions, David,
on healthcare and everybody has their own
experience or their interface. Even doctors,
we tend to see it from our vantage point in
our specialty. But if we look broadly at the
entire system and we actually are not beholden
to any particular special interest or stakeholder
and can talk openly and honestly with a critical
view of the entire system, it's really two
fundamental root problems. Number one, pricing
failures and number two, inappropriate care
or the appropriateness of care. If we look
at the loss of competition in healthcare and
how, um, you can't get a price for basic services,
people have a right to be angry. And when
those services, 20% of the time are unnecessary,
which is what our research from Johns Hopkins
has shown in a national survey of US doctors,
they say 21% on average of all medical cares,
unnecessary testing, even procedures, medications.
These are the two fundamental areas that we
can improve. And in the book, the price we
pay, I tried to find the disrupters nationally
who are actually fixing health care by addressing
needs to underlying root problem.
Now there are different philosophies that
would have one person here, what you just
laid out and go in the direction of, well,
the solution would be total free market for
profit, let everybody shop and do exactly
whatever it is they want. Let the sort of
laissez faire approach fix the problem. And
there are others who would hear what you said
and say, Oh, no, no, no. We need a completely
different system. We need one actually, uh,
where we can have bigger, uh, parties negotiating
on our behalf up to and including the government
through some kind of single payer system.
Which does one or the other strike you as
the best path forward to solve the two problems
you outlined?
Well, it'd be very honest, David, I actually
think that there's tremendous consensus in
the United States if we can lay out the issues
for what they really are, that price gouging
is wrong and that that price gouging happens
today and it will continue to happen if the
government is the payer. And by the way, the
government does not have a great track record
as being a very good negotiator. When you
deliver a baby in Boston, you can have that
done for $6,000 or $41,000 both at Harvard
hospitals. There's no difference in quality.
These are some times the same doctors. Price
Gouging has sadly become a way of doing business.
And if we can get rid of the waste in the
system, that entire spend that makes a lot
of people rich and care but is wasted money,
we could create an efficient marketplaces
and actually cut the waste in a way that's
bipartisan and it retains the private health
insurance system and at the same time keeps
the healthy Medicare government payer system
going strong.
So it sounds like you're saying you wouldn't
necessarily want to expand any government
involvement, you would want to keep Medicare
and maybe medicaid, but you would want to
improve the for profit healthcare system that
we have. Is that what I'm hearing?
Well, look, I applaud people who find Medicare
for all attractive because they want to get
rid of the waste. The problem is down the
stream longterm 100% of the time in every
country around the world, including our own
longterm governments, tighten the belt on
healthcare expenditures and you can be left
with a dilapidated system at 10 or 20 years
if we want to cut the waste, which is where
I think there's broad consensus, we can do
that by creating transparency within the system.
I opened the book the price we pay with a
group of doctors in the Washington DC area
that are gouging Medicare, that are taking
advantage of the system, that are our tax
payers are funding a group of doctors doing
unnecessary procedures all day long. That
will continue with Medicare for all. That
doesn't stop. So if we, if we just look at
competition and transparency, we can actually
reduce the waste because I personally believe
David, that we already spend enough money
in America to give everybody gold-plated healthcare.
Oh yeah. There's no question that we do. I
guess I'm not sure that I agree with you because,
yeah. Okay. So I think if you say to basically
any American, do you want to get rid of waste
in the healthcare system? Basically every
American would say, yes, I do want to get
rid of waste. The problem is that many Americans
see profit in an area where there is completely
inelastic demand as part of the waste that
should be removed. There are people who see
a system that requires medical billing experts
on both the insurance side and the provider
side as a form of waste, which we could get
rid of through some kind of government centered
program. So I do agree with you that waste
is bad and Americans want to get rid of it.
I don't think that there is as much agreement
as maybe you're suggesting as to what constitutes
that waste though.
Well, if we can agree that there's a tremendous
amount of waste, if we can agree that walking
into a New York hospital and having a bill
of $70,000 is agregious when the market price
is six to seven there's a tremendous amount
of waste there that can be cut without all
of the infighting that's partisan about what's
the great philosophy to dominate healthcare.
These are, this is the low hanging fruit in
the system and trust me, nobody has been more
aggressive in fighting the profiteering philosophy
and medicine that has taken over and ruin
the medical profession in certain of America
than me and my team. We go to hospitals, we
call out CEOs. We just did a giant expos say
of hospitals that sue patients in the state
of Virginia. A study that came out this week
and Jama showed that some hospitals about
10% aggressively take their patients to court
when they can't afford their bill.
We have called them out and in the hospital,
that was the worst offender announced they're
going to stop suing patients as a result of
our work in the NPR piece that ensued. So
we have been calling out people that have
been using prophet to take advantage of people
all across the country. And you're absolutely
right. It's wrong. It erodes the great public
trust of our medical profession. Right. Hospitals
were built to be a safe haven, a refuge for
the sick and injured regardless of their race,
creed, or ability to pay. That is the charter
of most us hospitals, many of which were bayed
were built on charity or built by churches
or by land grants from the community.
Yeah, so let's, I mean, let's focus in on
that a little bit because that may be something
my audience doesn't know about. I think my
audience probably understands the philosophical
differences sort of underlying the, the idea
of the systems that we're talking about. Talk
a little bit about the fact that there are
lawsuits against patients by hospitals. Talk
about the wage garnishment. Also that I think
many in my audience have no idea is even a
thing that hospitals do have mechanisms for
actually garnishing the wages of former patients
for unpaid medical bills.
Sure. Well, my research team started looking
at the markup on medical bills, identifying
extreme outlier facilities, hospitals, even
physicians who are charging 23 times more
than what the Medicare allowable amount is.
When we would approach hospitals, CEOs around
the country and say, ask them why are you
charging five times more than the next hospital
that sees the same case mix and payer mix?
The answer was always, well, we have secretly
negotiated contracts with insurance. Don't
worry, Marty, nobody pays those bills. So
we did some research and found out, no, a
lot of people are expected to pay that bill
in full and those people are expected to pay
that bill and if they don't, they're taken
to court and sued by a hospital and have their
paycheck garnished or liens put on their homes.
And we found one hospital that has sued 24,000
people in a town that by census data has 28,000
people living in it.
We went to New Mexico and in the book the
price we pay, I visited some of these courthouses
where we found the courthouse transformed
into a taxpayer funded collections agency
for the hospital. Lives ruined. I mean these
are hardworking Americans who's been financially
devastated, right. Most people don't live
like you and I, David, right. We are relatively
wealthy in the United States, right? God's
been to me, I have a good life as a surgeon
at Johns Hopkins. Most of America has less
than $500 of cash in savings. They live a
very different life and healthcare has forgotten
them and we refer to them as if they've done
something wrong. Like they've been irresponsible
and failed to get health insurance. No, these
people have health insurance. Our research
shows that they're insured, they're working.
The most common place they work is Walmart.
Number two is us postal workers, workers that
Lowe's nurses and housekeepers at hospitals
being sued by their own facility. Uh, we did
the expo say on Mary Washington Hospital.
We're now looking at UVA, which gets taxpayer
funding and sues a lot of people. Memphis,
uh, the baptist system just highlighted and
Propublica, uh, in New Mexico. So we're finding
hospitals around the country that are violating
the public trust of our great medical profession.
We're calling them out. We're doing this@restoringmedicine.org.org
and so far the first hospital that we talked
to has announced they are going to stop suing
patients.
Would someone have recourse to say that they,
they were sort of in a situation of, of duress
when they were in the situation where they
sort of agreed to receive certain treatment
because in certain emergency situations or
even urgent situations, you're, you're not
exactly sort of commonly stepping back the
way you would. If you're thinking about choices
for buying a car and making a decision. You're
in a situation where a doctor says this is
the procedure you need. Then later you end
up getting sued for something which, which
I would argue there is a sort of analogous
duress type of situation. Is that recourse
that these sue lawsuit victims can, can sort
of try to employ?
Yes, but David, to be honest, they're too
scared. They are how are served at home by
a sheriff's deputy that wakes him up at seven
in the morning. We founded some cases and
they're told to come to court and they come
to court and are asked a question, do you
owe this money? They're afraid of perjuring
themselves. They don't really understand what's
happening. They just say yes and then they
have to provide their routing number and account
number in the back of the courthouse to the
hospital who pulls the money out of their
savings or their paycheck has garnished or
Eileen has put on their home. We have been
representing patients pro bono as best we
can. I will list my name as the medical expert
on their case for free and I will argue to
the judge, the patient doesn't owe the money.
I can't mow your lawn and charge you $50,000
without a contract.
There's gotta be an agreement. Many people
are asking, I want to know the price of what
it's going to cost to deliver a baby beforehand.
60% of medical care is shoppable. That is
it's elective, right? No one's suggesting
we give you a price if you get shot and need
to have a heart valve replaced in the, in
the trauma bay. Okay. We're talking about
elective care hospitals get their act together,
physician groups, healthcare, the elite, the
medical establishment, and figure out a way
to do honest and fair, transparent billing
to patients and give them a price before the
service. Many of these patients sued, asked
for a price and were told the runaround, the
typical run around. It's common in hospitals.
Um, if you are somebody paying out of pocket
or out of network, which is a fast growing
group of Americans and you need to deliver
a baby, don't you think you should be able
to look up what it costs at different hospitals,
assuming it's an uncomplicated delivery.
So we've argued to the judges. There is no
valid contract. People come to us in a hospital
under duress. They are stressed. They're scared,
right? When I see a patient in the emergency
room or in my clinic with who was told they
have cancer, there is one emotion that dominates
their mind and that is they're petrified.
They're scared. We have historically been
a refuge for people when they are hurting.
Now we've got patients in the community saying
in Virginia, one woman said, I'm at home and
sick and scared to go to the hospital. They've
sued me twice. That is violating this great
public trust that we've had. And I think doctors
and nurses and everyone at a hospital are
starting to speak up. And we're seeing this
now with our restoring medicine Facebook page
and other, uh, venues.
The book is called the price we pay what broke
American health care and how to fix it. It's
available now on Amazon and we've been speaking
with the books author, Dr Dr Marty McCarry.
Thanks so much for talking to us about it.
Does today great to be with